the census symposium is meant to bring
together artists scientists humanists of
various flavors including
anthropologists and philosophers to
think about embodiment the Census and
how we understand those things
scientifically humanistically culturally
philosophically we're focusing of the
symposium musically on the work of Alvin
Lucier who's been working on the border
between music and acoustics for his
entire career I am sitting the same one
you are in now I am recording some of my
speaking voice the work that he'll be
performing I am sitting in a room
exploits the resonant frequencies of
whatever room it is that he's sitting in
and through a process of iterative
feedback amplifies those frequencies
until the sound that remains is very
difficult to interpret as speech I'm
sitting in a room is one of the most
self-contained pieces of art that has
ever or could ever exist and you wrote
me in an email that the idea for the
piece had been triggered by the work of
Bose I had worked with the scientist he
said you know last night I went to a
lecture at MIT by this man Bose was
developing a loudspeaker you're using
this in a reverberant field and maybe
I'll talk a little bit about and he
tests his speakers by recycling sounds
back into the speakers
I thought well that's something I should
try out and I did and that's how I got
this piece I stayed up all night doing
it you know to avoid sounds from outside
and I thought it was wonderful but
somehow it didn't hit me too later I
don't think interesting the Center for
art science and technology is an
institute wide initiative to try and
foster this very important discussion
about how technology changes us and how
we might want to change technology in
addressing our place in the environment
in the city in the world and reverb is a
primary ingredient in music production
this is an example of a song you guys
probably know it's for the love of money
by The O'Jays
and I've got just the introduction here
it's just a bassline and what the
engineer did is he plays the first
little riff which is the first five
seconds here with quite a lot of reverb
on it sounds like it's in a stadium and
then he turns it off over the second
repetition so the fact that these things
are used as tricks in music production
again is is evidence that the brain has
got a lot of sensitivity to this the
synergy is the serendipities of being in
the same space of having an artist
sitting next to a neurologist or a sound
artist sitting next to a technician who
does simulations of sound I mean these
are the kinds of serendipitous
encounters that I think create entirely
new realms of culture and that's I think
something exciting that MIT does really
well
please welcome Alvin Lucier
[Applause]
somebody said my music is about
revealing sounds that are always there
but you've never heard them exactly I am
sitting in a room the same one you are
in now I am recording the sound of my
speaking voice and I'm going to play it
back into the room again and again until
the resonant frequencies of the room
reinforced themselves so that any
semblance of my speech with perhaps the
exception of rhythm is destroyed I am
sitting in the world the same one you
are in now I am recording the sound of
my speaking is what we are listening to
the result of creative control on his
part is it the result of a kind of
weirdly alien inhuman emanation from
within what we take to be a normal human
body
[Music]
and my teeth that an important place for
me you are important to my TV
oh no I'm serious I mean our students
know your music often because my
colleagues and I play it for them what
but they hear it they get